[inaudible].
Okay.
So after the march,
during the march,
before the march of this thing is just becoming more and more political.
As you said,
you guys are getting up there and you want to,
you know,
sort of have your moment,
but there are certain issues you don't understand where politicians reaching out
to you.
Uh,
I know that,
you know,
Kyle cashew shoe of his,
talked to Marco Rubio a couple of times.
I mean,
how deep did this go in terms of reaching every part of American society?
Sure.
We,
um,
we reached out to a lot of people and a lot of people reached out to us.
There were a lot of conservatives that we,
we were speaking to about the issue.
I have a couple of friends who went to gun groups to talk about it,
sat down with some very big gun advocates in their areas,
not really in the country,
but notable where they were to talk about the issue.
And
the,
I know that the rest of my group was really interested in opening up and talking
about this again,
I was the shitty one in March for our lives.
Um,
I,
I wanted to stir some shit.
You know,
I wanted to cause trouble.
I wanted to make,
I wanted to own the conservatives the same way a lot of conservatives want to
own the libs.
I mean that's what it's about right now.
People,
people play games where they're trying to one up each other and you know,
I just,
I was trying to do that.
I was trying to make politicians,
I didn't like look bad as opposed to say what can we do?
Yeah,
when I went up there
and I was at where your folks or anyone saying,
you know,
maybe ease up on Twitter or like,
just just because you're going to get,
no matter what,
even if everything you said was factually right and came from the right place
and all that,
just the amount of hate you're going to get while you're still a young person in
the morning.
So it cannot be fun.
My mom is,
her sole existence in the world is to make everybody in the world happy and love
each other.
So she said to me,
be nice and loving.
My Dad,
who is a bit of a political advocate himself,
agrees with me on a lot of things and sometimes he would tell me to ease up.
Sometimes he would tell me to,
you know,
be be a little bit rougher.
But he also said,
and this is why I think my parenting from my mom,
Stepdad,
dad step mom was so great,
was they said,
do what you think is right and don't let people put their hooks in you.
And I did.
I let,
I let people manipulate me a bit because I thought that they were kindred
spirits.
But you know,
my parents,
I'm lucky enough to have parents who say,
believe what you believe.
If I my,
you know,
my parents are all liberal.
But if I came home and said,
I'm,
if I came home with a trunk 2020 hat,
which I do not expect to do unless some drastic change happens in my life,
although I know you're not thrilled with the Democrats at the moment,
I'm gonna Throw the Democrats at the moment,
but I'm not thrilled with Democrats.
At the moment because they're not being good Democrats,
not because they're Democrats,
but you know,
we'll get to that.
I um,
but if I came home and I told my parents that I would vote for the opposite of
what they would vote for,
they would say,
if you're doing it because you think it's right,
you're going to do it.
And I'm very grateful for that.
Yeah.
So we're,
do you stand on gun control?
Generally because I think what happened was they,
at the event at March for our lives,
there were a lot of people are getting up there and they were saying things that
implied,
and I think this is the way a lot of people on the right took it.
It's not about sensible gun control.
This is ultimately about taking away all the guns.
And that of course is the fear of most of the people on the right.
And there were a couple of the students,
there was one young girl,
I don't remember who said we're going to start with bump stocks,
but we're coming for all the guns or something to that effect.
And that that feeds right into the people on the right who go,
all right,
well now we're not going to talk.
[inaudible] negotiates who like better laws.
You guys are Mazda.
Dot.
Exactly,
and then because of that then the people on the left and you guys go,
well,
all right,
see now they don't want to talk at all so we're not going to talk.
And then you end up sort of exactly where we're at at the moment.
It's an,
this is it.
Somebody told me this the other day,
it's a brilliant point.
The left and the right attack each other's worst arguments and that does nothing
for us.
But when it comes to my personal stance on guns,
there's some,
there are some differing opinions amongst my friends from our,
for our lives,
but we all,
we all agree with some similar things.
Personally,
I think that as long as people who are responsible can carry concealed firearms,
particularly handguns in the country in many situations,
the countries a safer place.
I also think that there is not a strong vetting process for people to purchase
these firearms.
And a lot of people just get guns and a lot of these people are not the good guy
with the gun because I think the good guy with a gun argument is just a hasty
generalization.
I understand it in some ways because I intend to concealed carry when I'm an
adult because I intended to have a family and I intend to shoot anybody who
tries to kill my family.
And
I,
I assumed that that even that position right there probably puts you on the outs
with a Lotta,
a lot of your crew,
the outs conceptually,
you know,
we all respect each other's opinions.
If somebody in March for our lives,
and this is nobody in March where he lives,
but if somebody said,
I want to eliminate all guns,
I'd say,
okay,
well let's talk about that.
So you know,
my friends respect me for what I think and I respect them some.
It's difficult.
It's a difficult thing to respect people who disagree with you for those things.
Do you find that
you know guys and girls your age are able to have these conversations without
killing each other?
There was a terrible choice of words without sure,
but without being at each other's throats,
I think more than adults are right now.
Is that possible?
Because that seems to be a through line with you that you're friends with.
A lot of people have different opinions.
I think we want to,
I think that a lot of people who want to aren't taking the right steps because
they're saying,
yes we can.
We can come to some common ground if you agree with me.
And there's a,
there's a want out there.
And that's something I'm really interested in because I come from a generation
that I believe puts principles and morals over money and political victories.
And I think that we've actually got a bright future now.
People will call me in insane,
Bobby Kennedy more on per se.
We have a bright future,
but I think we do.
I think we need to de stigmatize the conversation.
I had a lot of friends who,
who before seven months ago I would have thought were racist,
sexist,
bigoted,
homophobes who want the country to explode and want to destroy everybody who
isn't exactly like them,
and then I learned,
maybe that's not the case and I have a lot of friends who would have thought
that I was some leftist Beta cook shill who wanted,
who wanted a communists to take everybody's guns and kill them and then they
learn.
Maybe that's not the case.
I think our generation really is moving in a good direction when it comes to
smart conversations.
I just think we need a bit of a social revolution.
They're not a huge social revolution.
I love social revolutions.
This isn't that big revolutions.
Cool.
At beetles where La Miz level yet,
we're not at your guys.
We're not hearing that people sing the song and making me mad yet,
but we,
we need some,
we need a,
a movement towards respecting each other because look,
before all of this,
if I could have gotten rid of the right,
I would have,
and I know people who would have gotten rid of the left if they could have,
but it's not going to happen.
The parties might evolve over time.
I mean,
the parties,
the parties are flipping in a Lotta ways.
Why?
Well,
think about this.
The party of Lincoln is the only party that currently we're not the Democrat.
There are some Democrats who are like this,
but the majority of people who are running as admitted white supremacists are
part of the party of Lincoln.
So a lot of,
a lot of switches happen there.
Um,
I mean,
you've got some really awful rhetoric out there from folks like Candice Owens
who will say,
we'll talk about the left plantation.
Look,
I think identity politics are dangerous,
but calling saying that the real racists or the Democrats is a hasty
generalization.
I think that,
I think there's actually some truth to it.
There's a difference between the the the liberals and the left.
Well now you're speaking my leg,
but the thing is you can't pigeonhole them together,
especially in all the right word for that.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can't pigeonhole them together.
I'm a liberal,
but I think that all men and women are created equal and need to be respected
equally,
whereas people farther to the left will say as a,
as a white,
cisgender,
heterosexual male,
I don't have the right to say any of that.
Look you.
A friend of mine,
Michael Skolnik,
who I've worked with before,
said something to me that I really appreciated,
which was you can't judge somebody by the hand they're dealt.
You judge them by how they elected to play.
That hand,
people farther to the left will judge me by the hand I'm dealt.
I grew up in a pretty well off family.
I had a pretty easy childhood.
I could have walked around my neighborhood without fearing death,
which is something that some of my friends I made in Chicago,
we're not able to have,
but they'll say that my opinion is less valid than anybody's because I don't
deal with the struggles they do.
I have an incredible amount of empathy for people who are not as privileged as I
am.
I believe that white privilege exists.
I don't believe it's as systematic or,
or,
um,
really structural as people say it is.
I don't think the government exists to oppress people,
but white privilege I believe exists.
I believe that there are certain situations where I will be,
where I will be in a better place because I'm a white,
cisgender,
heterosexual male.
Again,
it's not this large,
oppressive force.
The people treat it like,
but it's something we need to address.
And that's,
that's the real thing I'm talking about recently,
which is we can find common ground on these issues and not try to push each
other away.
Because in my view,
in my view,
white privilege exists and people will say,
well,
no,
because,
um,
in many situations on the sat,
African American students were given points in Asian students were,
were deducted points.
And that proves that,
that,
well,
I got myself into an yeah,
I don't want to,
we don't have to go too far down down that road because we could have a whole
other conversation on that.
Cause I,
I,
I actually don't agree with you on that,
but,
but that's the point of this mean that's the point.
And I'm still learning.
You're still learning it.
It's kind of a beautiful thing.
Actually.
I'm 17 I can hardly smell.
I'm not the expert on Shit.
And that's actually the point in the new podcast I'm putting out.
Yeah.
Soon it's called Cameron knows nothing.
Uh,
do you watch game of Thrones?
I do.
Look,
you grit told me.
Yeah.
I don't know.
And it's true.
I,
you know,
I had my own personal views on abortion.
I actually,
I watched a video of yours.
You and I have this pretty much the same exact view on the 20 weeks guy.
Um,
but I also have not taken enough science classes.
I also do not,
I have not conversed with enough women who have had abortions.
My opinions mean Jack Shit,
but I'm allowed to have them.
You know,
it's,
I'm a 17 year old boy,
so there's only so much I could truly say about pro lifers pro choice,
but I'm allowed to say it.
Yeah.
And you know,
in Cameron knows nothing.
I'm going to tell you guys what I think,
but doesn't mean it's right.
Yeah.
Where do you think that attitude comes from within you?
Because it seems to me that I think a lot of what's happening right now is I see
adults that are now afraid to say what they think and you know,
they think that the mom's going to come after them,
which is completely legit.
They think it might hurt their job opportunities or things like that.
Yeah.
The mob,
whichever,
whichever way it is.
Right.
I mean,
I think,
but we see boycotts on both sides and I think a lot of misguided anger often.
Uh,
but I think most people need a little bit more of what you just did there,
which is I just am what I am,
you know,
maybe convince me as some other stuff,
but I'm trying to learn here.
I don't want to hurt anybody.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I want the government to crack down on guns.
That doesn't mean I want the government to oppress you.
I believe that there's a certain amount of time somebody just should have access
to an abortion.
And I think that abortion should be more accessible just for a certain amount of
time.
But I don't want to kill babies and I don't want to oppress women.
I want the world to be a better place.
You want the world to be a better place.
Um,
I dunno about,
about,
you know,
anybody up in the booth,
but they seem really nice.
Yeah,
they pretty good.
Yeah.
Uh,
Todd Macfarlane,
I hand selected these people.
Exactly.
Topic falling wants the world to be a better place.
David Hogg wants the world to be a better place.
Uh,
Jordan Peterson,
one of the world.
We all pretty much all of us do.
I'm actually glad you mentioned Jordan Peterson because you know I'm on tour
with him right now and one of the things that I find is at first if I meet a ton
of people your age,
I'd say the bulk of the people that are coming,
there are young people probably probably right around your age,
1718 into into their probably early thirties and it's male,
female,
gay,
straight,
black,
white,
the whole thing.
But it's very obvious to me that he's providing some level of guidance that
somehow it seems that your generation kind of missed.
Now it sounds like your,
your folks are pretty great and your extended family and all that,
but do you sense that there is some missing piece here that partly,
I don't know that there's like some,
I discussed this last week with Peter Teal that there was some disconnect
between the baby boomers,
my parents age and that my guys,
the gen x people,
we never had our moment or something.
And then we've sort of handed it off to you guys,
the millennials and that there's,
I'm Gen x,
Gen z actually.
Wow.
Wendy's are three or four years older than I am.
All right.
Oh man,
we're all,
I don't that hit that we handed it off to the,
to the generation of people who grew up with cell phones,
immediate access to knowledge.
Those
are the best and worst thing to ever happened to us.
If I wanted to get to a hospital,
I can get to a hospital much easier with a cell phone if I want to look up a
fact,
forgetting the fact that facts are difficult right now because it's a fact that
facts are difficult to find.
Um,
that,
you know,
I can do it.
But also I,
I've,
before all of this,
I was very,
very obsessed with my own image.
Not because I thought I had a good one,
but because I wanted it to be good.
I was posting things online because I wanted people to think I had a cool life.
I mean,
I did.
I was,
I had a great life,
but I wanted people to know that.
And,
and it,
it the hyperconnectivity of social media,
which is a term I stole from many Ben Platt interviews where he's talking about
his musical.
Do you have enhancing,
I don't want him to see this and think I'm stealing from another,
the hyperconnectivity of social media is,
um,
is,
is a good and bad thing.
But I think the problem here,
and I think that,
you know,
folks like Jordan,
I'm a big fan of Jordan and I'm a big fan of yours.
Don't get a big head.
Um,
uh,
people,
people like you guys,
one of the things that you advocate for is his conversation and people on the
right,
young people on the right that I know and I'm friends with,
they want to own the lips.
This is all about proving them wrong and saying like,
facts don't care about your feelings.
I agree.
Facts by definition don't care about your feelings.
But there's also a logic,
which is kind of the middle between the two really.
And that's the interpretation and the insight and the fact where w,
you know,
if we,
if we only based everything in fact,
which a lot of young people on the right do,
we're just talking about the past.
You can look at the future and you can assess facts,
but a lot of,
a lot of young people on the right one to prove people wrong and a lot of young
people on the left I've seen wants to want to make people want to make people
who disagree with them look worse.
It's all about making the other look worse.
The right wants to show that the left is a bunch of copies and left wants to
show that the rights of bunch of fascists and that's a waste of time.
That is a,
that is what is harming our country right now.
I think Donald Trump's rhetoric is dangerous and harms our country,
but Trump is,
is the,
is a symptom of something greater like prison.
Obama said when he made his return that made all of my liberal friends think
Jesus came back,
which is,
you know,
Trump.
Trump is the result of a country where the people who love Trump are loving him
more than ever.
And the people who hate Trump or I hated him more than ever because we are
divided,
you know,
with our rhetoric is driving these,
driving everybody in different directions.
That's why you see the rise of democratic socialism.
And that's why you see the rise of more and more people coming out and saying
things that are stupid because they have the first man right to do it.
Look,
if you say something I don't like,
I will defend it with my life.
I will defend with my life.
You're right to say it,
but people are mixing,
being not PC and being a jerk and and right now we're driving apart.
We need to come together,
stop attacking each other.
Both sides are equally as guilty.
Certain sides in certain situations are obviously guiltier.
But it,
it's,
it's bullshit.
So do you sense a little more flexibility on the ability to talk to people on
the right than on the left?
Because you know that that's been a sort of
big part of what's going on with me.
Like I get invited to go to these conservative things and turning point USA and
I talk about being gay married and I'm pro choice and against the death penalty
and all of these things that are thought of as leftist things,
but they invite me,
we have a great time.
I take a zillion selfies with the kids after and all that stuff where there
doesn't seem to be that flexibility over there.
And now I don't want to harp on this because I get your greater point,
which is we got to get past this.
It's where it's what I am.
I do see something on one side,
especially with young people that has become more corroded I would say.
Then a then on the other,
here's what I'll say,
I'll say the left cares too much about people in the right doesn't care enough
and I'll tell you what I mean,
cause they're,
they're equally is wrong here.
Young people on the right will attack you with facts and in in either positive
or negative ways and they're opening a conversation very often I believe because
they want to prove you wrong.
That's what I've seen from that.
That's not a fact.
It's an opinion.
Whereas people on the left wants to accommodate for everybody so much that if
you say anything negative about anybody that they agree with,
they jump to their defense.
So I'll bring up the Israel argument,
which is an argument that I don't know enough about to form an opinion.
I truly do not.
But if you are a propeller,
that sounds like pretty much everybody to exactly be being pro Palestine doesn't
mean you hate the Jews necessarily.
And being pro Israel doesn't mean that you hate everybody who you hate
Palestinians.
But I'll talk to people on the right and they'll,
they'll be happier to talk about it then people on the left.
But the second I say that,
you know,
Palestine should have land,
which again I don't,
I don't have a firm opinion on,
they'll say,
dude,
you're Jewish.
How could you say that?
I'll say because people are people and then I'll talk to people on the left
about,
and I'll say there's a,
there are a lot of concerns of terror and they'll say,
don't you dare call everybody everybody who's Palestinian terrorist and on and
on both sides.
Your d so,
so yes,
I think the right is more open to conversation,
but I think that more people on the right are trying to lure you into a cave
where they can prove you wrong.
I don't want to be proven right or wrong right now.
I want to discuss,
cause my opinions on things.
I've changed.
My opinions really are not taking a one 80 I have all my opinions,
but my opinion on opinions is changing.
That's,
that's the most important thing I'd like to highlight here.
Yeah,
if I'm talking,
I used to think that,
and we've talked about this,
I used to think that if he didn't agree with me,
you hate it.
But now I've learned a different thing and I'm not.
And what I'm advocating for now is I'm not asking people to change their
perspectives.
I'm asking people to stop having your feet so firmly on the ground when you're a
child.
Because I'm a child,
you know,
I can't rent a car.
I can't smoke a cigarette,
nor do I intend to.
But at the end of the day,
I can't tell you about,
I can tell you with authority about economics,
I could tell you what I think.
I haven't taken any comm class or finance class and we need it.
Yeah,
you're already doing better than most experts on CNN.
I think
people on the left and the right.
And you just need to realize that facts are facts.
Feelings are feelings,
logic,
his logic.
But the more and more we try to prove each other wrong,
the less progress we're going to make.
Cause I,
I have had the mindset that,
which is why I understand it.
I've had the mindset,
we're,
all I wanted to do is just own the conservatives.
And I know people who have had the mindset where all they want to do is own the
lips.
Yeah.
And by the way,
I know you're not just saying this because Kyle cashew who I've gotten to know
well who falls off and on the other side of this and you,
he's now working with turning point and he's,
you know,
trying to strengthen the second amendment and all sorts of other things.
You guys are friends and you guys are still able to talk about these things and
we are,
you know,
I had originally said maybe we could get both of you guys in here,
but we thought this would be a good opportunity to just to let you do your thing
and I'll have Kyle on separately,
but you guys are,
despite your differences,
you're,
you're able to talk
a lot of things.
Kyle does.
I don't like a lot of,
almost everything he says I disagree with are some things he says that I think
are inappropriate.
I've said some inappropriate stuff and,
and you know,
I understand if you don't agree with me and you want to come out and speak,
I,
I'm proud that I was able to speak after the shooting and Kyle did too.
So,
uh,
I haven't understood.
I have a deep understanding of his position.
So beyond the podcast,
and I will give you my word that I will do the podcast.
Oh,
please.
No,
I was,
yeah.
Well you asked me to do it.
The email was,
can you do my phone that I'm lucky enough to be here?
Yeah.
I'm more than happy to do it.
We'll,
we'll make that happen.
Um,
what,
what do you want to do?
Have you,
have you really been able to think about it at this point?
I know it's sort of an annoying question to ask a young person.
No,
I mean,
you know,
I can tell you what college I want to go to.
I can't tell you where I want to be in 50 years,
but I can tell you that right now I want to dedicate my time to do and what I
think is the best thing I could do with my platform because I have a large
platform for all the worst reasons.
And with great platform comes great responsibility.
Biderman exactly.
Uncle Ben said that,
I believe it wasn't uncle Ben,
but when you say uncle Ben on this show,
people might be like kindly talking about Ben Shapiro.
This is all the Ben Parker.
Um,
and I have a responsibility to do what I think is right and what I think is
right as advocating for what I believe in,
but also making sure that the conversation is,
is mended and healed because who better than the people who are about to become
adults to try and make sure that our next generation of adults knows how to work
together.
I mean you got Nelson and Rubio in Florida.
I'll give you a great example.
Nelson and Rubio have passed some great bills together because Nelson Rubio
don't see eye to eye to eye,
but they are able to put their differences aside.
They get along and I want more of that.
Yeah.
Well man,
I know a lot of people were worried about the future.
But I mean it's clear to me that your future is bright and if we can hand it
over whenever we can hand it over to,
to,
to people like you will be all right.
Cause this is,
this is everything that I've been trying to do here I think is summed up in the
way that you're trying to go forward with life.
It's,
it's pretty awesome really.
It's inspiring.
I appreciate that.
Let me ask you something and it's your show.
Oh,
I'm,
I'm gonna we're gonna switch to your,
flip it in motion.
You are in theater.
All right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so
what,
what are the qualities you're looking for in a candidate if you are going to
vote for them over president Trump in 2020.
Oh man,
you're really putting me on the spot here.
This is my show.
Look,
I've said this before,
but it seems to me that unfortunately the democratic socialist wing of the
Democrats has gone really far left.
I mean,
look,
the word socialist in the,
in the title now,
[inaudible] Dave Purge,
right?
I guess they're being honest for what they are and they're fighting for what
they believe in.
I happen to disagree with virtually all of it,
but that they're doing that.
They've basically purged what I think are the,
the remaining liberals,
as you said,
classical liberals before.
And I think unfortunately that leaves a lot of us.
It's why people watch my show because I've just been honest about what I see
here.
That leaves a lot of us suddenly with allies in places that we didn't think we
were going to have allies.
And it's sort of unfortunate in one way because you want to always think that
you can sort of stay home and fix things.
You've got to pop the bubble.
But at the moment I find my allies have certainly are libertarians on the right.
I think I can,
you know,
be allies and a lot of ways with Ben Shapiro,
even though we have differences on the margins,
like with abortion and some of that other stuff.
Um,
but I don't see at the moment when from when we're taping this right now,
I just don't see any hope in the short term for the Democrats.
My hope is that this thing implodes that they get probably half to get crushed
in the mid terms,
which is not looking likely,
but that they get crushed in the midterms and then they have a major course,
uh,
adjustment where they go,
we've got to return to liberalism.
Sure.
And that is the answer because I believe liberalism is the answer.
I think it's the only answer.
But if you know somebody that I should be paying attention to,
let me know because I don't see much.
We'll keep in touch and I know,
I know you've got a list.
I'll send you some liberals.
I,
um,
one more thing.
I know we're about on time.
What is your favorite musical and with which musical character do you identify
the most?
Oh Man.
Yeah.
And really going for it.
I can either do favorite superhero movie or something,
but let's go to that.
Well,
I was telling you during the break that I love,
I mean,
I really felt infinity war was spectacular.
I think it was just done right.
Loki has to be dead though.
That's,
that's the key thing I want.
But here's the thing,
I loved the Maura.
She's amazing.
She's a Badass.
But if they bring her back,
which they will bring her back,
she was killed in the process of getting this also.
And so they can say that once they destroy the stones or whatever,
however it may be,
they could bring her back and it'll be nice to see her back because I love her
as an actress.
I love her chemistry with everyone.
But that was a powerful for me.
You can't keep killing people and bringing them back.
That's why Loki has to be dead this time.
Which they basically made it sound like,
yeah,
I infinity war did a good job with,
you know,
Tony.
Tony has been in the MCU for what?
Like 20 movies and he didn't die Gomorrah.
This is our third film.
And I felt that I felt that debt.
I hate to tell you,
but she's,
well,
hate to tell her whatever she's going,
she's going to be alive.
But putting that aside against three musical,
you know,
I'm not a huge musical guy.
I'm not,
I know you don't want to hear that as well as a theater guy.
No,
not a huge muser girl.
I liked.
I liked Mama Mia.
Okay.
We can,
you can find some common ground.
You got some comments?
See that's what it's about.
Content.
Exactly.
Listen,
man,
we could've talked about marvel movies and all these other,
you gave me a lot of funny pop culture references before we started.
You have to,
you have to,
you know,
break new ground.
And that's what I was trying to do here.
That's what it's all about.
I have no doubt.
You have a bright future and you're probably going to be president.
Is that where this is all leading president of Stoneman Douglas High School's
Drama Club?
No,
because my dear friend,
uh,
she ran and she's doing a phenomenal job.
On that note,
guys,
follow Cameron on Twitter.
It's Cameron underscore.
Caskey.